benoît hamon c'est à replonger dans les
archives de ce fleuron donc comme on
l'appelle de l'industrie française un
fleuron présent dans les secteurs de
l'énergie on l'a dit et bien sûr dans le
secteur des transports avec le tgv
alstom aujourd'hui c'est 93 mille
salariés dans le monde
spécialisée dans le transport
ferroviaire et l'énergie
son chiffre d'affaires 20 milliards
d'euros quelle part est désormais loin
l'époque de la révolution industrielle
car l'histoire d'alstom commence au 19e
siècle avec la production de cette
locomotive à l'origine de ses premiers
modèles andré que schilling un alsacien
qui crée en 1839 une petite fonderie à
mulhouse
très vite l'industriel fait fortune son
usine s'agrandit à belfort
au début du 20e siècle ses héritiers
s'intéresse à un nouveau marché
l'électricité des projets nouveaux qui
précipite la naissance d'alstom en 1928
alstom la contraction d'alsace et de
thomson une société américaine
spécialisée dans les équipements
électriques
après la guerre nouveau tournant alstom
participent à la reconstruction du pays
alstom les huit mille ouvriers qui
depuis dix ans fabriquer dix mille comme
alstom devient un géant industriel le
groupe fabrique les premières turbines
nucléaires
acquia les chantiers de l'atlantique et
selon surtout dans l' aventure du tgp
aux commandes du train le plus rapide du
monde le président mitterrand
mais la belle machine se grippe à la fin
des années 90 alstom connaît ses
premières difficultés de nouvelles
turbines moins performantes de mauvais
choix stratégique alstom perd beaucoup
d'argent
à l'époque déjà d'état doit intervenir
parce qu'il faut qu'on fasse tout
pour sauver alstom pense qu'alstom c'est
un savoir faire
ces deux technologies chez les hommes
s'ensuivent une nouvelle restructuration
et à nouveau pdg le groupe se redresse
mais il rechute rattrapée par la crise
de l'énergie un secteur qu'alstom à
supporter en exporter comme ici en chine
où le plus grand barrage du monde est
équipée de turbines alstom une activité
énergie aujourd'hui mises en vente par
le groupe